so Curtis what brought you to story expo
2014 a friend of mine did it before the
expo before and I've been two to three
other pitch vests and he said this would
be different and he's right it's been
different so far and you flew out from
flew out from South Carolina oh and uh
you know I maintained a place here only
because if a meeting happens that I need
to go to I can just hop on a plane and
have a place here and that's happening
quite a few times but oh it is and and
so do you drop everything and drop
everything I teach so I have an
assistant take over my class on hop on a
plane so what do you teach criminal
justice okay criminal justice and yeah
it's it's you know I law enforcement
retired so I went to get my little
certificate and felt like it'd be a
great thing to do so love it love it so
the story that you came to pitch today
how long have you been working on this
idea i started wrote a book and came out
a no one juvenile justice 101 and toured
for a year on the book and I really
wrote that book just for people in the
industry that in my field because you
know dealing with juvenile crimes a lot
different than dealing with adult crime
you arrest a kid it's different so it
ended up being a novel that touched a
whole bunch of other people besides
workers in the juvenile world and so
went to Long Beach to speak at a
conference and then this producer asked
me to to write a screenplay and send it
to her and I did and they ended up
optioning screenplay nothing became of
that which is why I'm here because I
redid everything and at risk is what
it's called now so how many times have
you rewritten this I probably rewritten
this one may be seven times seven times
yeah I left out a lot of the things that
uh you know you're dealing with kids you
know unlike adults you become closer to
these families because it's not just the
kid you you have detained it's the
family so I lost eight kids doing that
that either murdered or was murdered
during my tenure with the prosecutor's
office
oh I had to go back and put some of
those things in because I couldn't
really deal with them they were too
fresh and so that's probably why seven
now ivory Whitney were written in seven
times why and I got to save it the
reason I actually do this is because I
met my brother when he was 12 never even
knew I had a brother and my dad said hey
here's here's your brother and he was
already in the gang 12 years old he ran
the whole neighborhood he's on trial now
for murder he murdered his girlfriend
last year but he told me after you read
my book I dedicated the book to him and
he said you know you gotta do the show
this is my life he went to juvenile
detention when he was 13 he's 33 now
he's been in jail the whole time so
that's why that's my number one project
right because I want to see a TV series
dedicated to just even how crime the
story is just crazy so so that's been
the driving force for you is this this
personal thing and knowing these also
these different people that have passed
away all right so it's not just yeah
you're hoping to get a deal and why it's
way more than that way more net for me
you know if it were just to get a deal i
would stopped a long time ago why
because i feel like you know if it was
for the money you know Hollywood's a
different animal to deal with you know
and not that I can't take rejection but
usually as my wife tells me I don't have
patience for that you know so someone
says no a few times i'll just say okay
I'll do something else I don't take it
personal but this one I have to stick
with my paralegal at the time a year
before I left Liz she said you know
there's no way you can stop this until
TV show happens because we lost a great
kid that year he got out of a gang we
got him into an alternative school he
was literally walking to school that day
down its first day of school in florence
south carolina just outside of myrtle
beach and that kid for the whole summer
the community service did whatever and
he said mr. ray please keep me in this
community service thing because if i go
home to the neighborhood they're going
to get me so work me during the day time
he begged he rode his bike five miles
just to come downtown to work in the
city center and in da his first day of
school that killed him because of
something he did the year prior so so
those are the stories that i have to
have to keep this going you know and
when I pitch of course I use that
because it's real you can't make him up
as anyone ever told you to tone down the
violence because it's always yeah yeah
actually you know it's funny you say
that a couple years ago my manager or
not and my former manager and he said
before you go in I gotta tell you
something they shot me some notes and he
said you know I don't know how to tell
you this but they think it's going to be
a black thing and they think it's too
violent we don't want to be gang stuff
and all that and I said well they
haven't read my book you know because of
my book I have people from all walks I
had before Columbine I dealt with a kid
who threaten to blow up his school and
he had his family was rich to doctors
and he had a lab downstairs in the
basement and he could have done it so
it's not about just the gangs and about
black kids in the neighborhood someone
said to me at pretty much before that
same thing happened that this needs to
be a wire thing it will happen you know
if it's a liar thing and I said you know
I'm not in this to redo the wire or a
black-white thing crime reaches across
all colors nationalities you know a
crime has no color and so when I write I
write for everyone I have kids selling
pills in rich neighborhoods boxes of
pills they have pill parties their
parents drive Jags their doctors and
lawyers did they didn't see it that way
so you know they thought it was going to
be a black thing
so those are kind of walls you run into
but you still keep going still keep
going yeah there's many reasons thank
you yeah many people one girl gave me
her high school diploma I got her out of
an alternative I got her out of regular
high school and got him into an
alternative school had no idea that she
was graduating valedictorian and her mom
kept calling me one day and said hey can
you make her graduation she really wants
you there and I said well sure you know
I didn't think anything about it but
when I got there she started talking
about this guy that she took a knife to
school gorgeous girl green eyes you know
really light skin from her she's mixed
you know and everybody hated her at
school the girls because he was pretty
and all the boys liked her she took a
night to school to protect herself and
that's how I got her anyway her name is
Joan easy and so Joe got up gave her
valedictorian speech and was talking
about this guy and her mom elbows me and
start smiling she talked about you I
said what well I had gotten her into the
alternative school because my high
school girlfriend was the guidance
counselor at that school I called Joey
up and she got her in nobody would take
her and she was a straight-a student so
and now she's married with kids and
doing well so so these are the things
that you know I did it so long so I have
probably more stories than most but
those are the reasons why I gotta keep
going you know so she gave me a high
school diploma it's on my wall at home
so yeah Curtis did you get to pitch up
yes yes I ditched ok stud is I think
five times so far and how much time did
you get I 5-10 minutes you know it's
kind of you know it's who you getting
and whether or not they ring the bell so
to speak you know well they're leaving
about uh yeah I think they there was a
bill 11 pitch but
then you know it stopped I don't know
somebody said it's probably annoying but
I but yeah there's like two to five
minutes and then one minute 11 pitch I
got ten minutes so the guy didn't want
me to get up so so hot so how did it go
like well I went well I I'm actually I'm
pitching Britain 15 projects at this
point and I pitched five today and at
risk I'm pitching three times obviously
it's mine you know number one but I'm
also pitching to other projects other
near and dear to my heart so one is
front it's to logo TV my cousin came out
and I'm the only one it you know we'll
deal with her now and so I wrote a
project called front on her life and
then the other one call hazmat it's it's
a crime thriller terrorist thing from
the mine went to Iraq three or four
times came back and dealt with some
interesting things that happen when he
got back as a as an injured person and
but he failed a terrorist attack in
Charleston South Carolina you know
nobody ever really heard of it so so I
wrote it yeah so anyway they kept the
dirty bomber there by the way and
someone was trying to get revenge for
Charleston keeping the dirty bomber and
their brig in the Navy Yard okay yeah so
they were trying to to us f student
universe South Florida students came up
and they were going to engineering
students they're going to construct
these robots to blow up some things
because they were family members of this
guy so anyway so I wrote that so that's
on pidgin as well yeah but most of your
what you write about is all juvenile
justice um that's what i right most
about because you know that was my feel
I actually I've written all 13 episodes
that I was required to write in order to
pitch it to executives yeah sony and a
few other places I've been what did you
expect would happen at story expo what
did you have certain notions about it or
you said I'm coming here with no yeah I
never have expectations at all when I
come to the
I started coming to these you know for
Ken to my first one I used to fly out
here and act like I belong that's kind
of how I do things and I'd walk around
la Beverly Hills like I lived here and
there were pitch fest so I'd go to them
so you know I kind of put myself in
places that I think I need to be and
things happen so a lot of my friends say
you're crazy man you going out there
with nothing and you know but I met
contacts and when I moved out here all
my friends already already you know made
my friends in my contacts so so but I
never really have expectations when I
come to these I just have conversations
about my work do you think having been
in law enforcement you just felt like
it's like you've seen probably worse
than anybody since so it's like how bad
could it be maybe somebody just says all
right great yeah you know it's funny you
say that i was at a firm it I don't want
to name drop but it's a huge company and
they were getting into TV they were big
on management the music side when you
walk into offices and everybody's area
they've managed everyone anyway the guy
calls and my management says we can
achieve it you got anything and so he
sends me over and the guy listened and
it was great great pitch had a good time
and then he says something that really
pissed me off he said ok you know we got
you know this rapper and that rapper and
you know I said well why'd you name
those guys because they're tall it was a
short you know well they're black you
know and so he tried the thing again so
I said listen this is a show like I told
you earlier it's about it's about
everyone's by kids in trouble kids in
trouble come in many flavors he goes
well you're going to regret it if you
leave this office without a deal you got
regret it so I said listen man I've seen
people on the street dead I've walked
through crime scenes where they would
blow your mind I've seen a kid pick up
an Uzi and spray a neighborhood when I
was on patrol this is nothing you know
and my manager tried to stop me you know
and Tom you're gonna you know mess it up
and I said law
I mean look I want to be in business
with someone who wants to be business
with me I won't be in business with
someone who's not mean and nasty you
know I've already dealt with that in the
police world I don't want to deal with
that here so this guy tells me I'll
never work again in Hollywood whatever I
don't you know but I'm not going to
leave until he hears what I had to say
so so anyway needs to say that didn't
work out but but I made my point have
you considered just making the film on
your own because I have ideas that you
want and you don't want the studio or
whomever yeah change I have I have I
actually had a guy approached me I grew
up with a really rich guy and his family
his dad was a senator and you know it's
old money South money Oh cotton money
and it's funny because they they're his
family owned my family back in the day
we never even knew it growing up
together the only real estate company
they're huge anyway he came to me and
asked me if I wanted to make it but he
wanted to control everything that's kind
of person is and I'm not really big on
and he was I was all about the dollar
signs you know and I'm not rich you know
but it's not about the money for me that
Ben might one of my other projects maybe
but not this one yeah I'm just way too
passionate about this you know so he
wanted to commercialize it and I'm not
really big on that so yeah we still talk
so so that works so this was near where
you grew up yes yes yes it's Columbia
South Carolina and Florence Colombia I
worked in mostly I was the arbitrator of
the year for one year and I had to go to
all the other arbitrator's in the 16
circuits and I had to supervise them for
that one year and it so I saw stuff all
over and you know the misconception is
crime happens just in big cities but
little cities I you know some of the
worst crime I've seen has been in small
towns and I think one of the reasons is
because kids are bored they have nothing
No Boys and Girls Clubs there you know
then you got Barney Fife as the sheriff
and his sidekick you know and these kids
know that
gangs have taken over small-town America
like crazy at least in our safe so yeah
I've seen seen a whole lot in those
towns yeah so what kind of notes have
you gotten aside from making it more
commercialized or keeping it one theme
yeah what are their notes have you
gotten about your work I've actually
gotten really it's funny because I
pitched earlier to a company that I
pitched on virtual pitch fest and if
you've heard him I pitched on that site
and the guy said well we're gonna say no
now but if you add this maybe we'll say
yes so I noticed he was here and I said
okay well I'm going to take him at his
word you know and does so I added those
two elements he suggested I added more
of a political element and the
community-based element and so when I
sat down with him a while ago I said hey
you're the guy that told me to do this
you know I showed on the pitch I
actually ran it off you know from
virtual pitch fest he said oh yeah I'm
right Matt and I said well that made it
a better piece and so he was you know
flattered by that of course but he said
dude I got to see it you know but I
wanted to want him to see that you know
you're the one that told me you do this
you can't say no now no oh look he he
actually said okay you're right I can't
say no so he got screenplay I brought it
with me in a gave it to him yeah so some
of them do do you keep copies of your
screenplays in your car I do I keep them
keep them gosh I've got I keep two in my
bag and you know I just believe in fact
I gave one to someone I met in the hall
we were talking and the guy is your
calling card you know of course i was
i'm not gonna walk around on the hall
pass and not to everyone but if I feel
like the conversation warrants it I gave
it to this person because he's a
struggling writer and he said to me man
i just don't know you know what to do I
pitch it and they don't get me in
whatever and so I gave it to him and I
showed him seven versions is what it
took to get to this point so he left I
think but uh I just gave it to him I
said man it takes you a while you can't
quit you know because really you know
you come to these pitch fest and you're
overwhelmed especially if you've never
been the one one guy in the bathroom I
told him he was so nervous I said man
look you know and I don't know why me
everybody's asking me you know but uh
but I don't care i'll tell him i said
you know a man look this guy put his
pants the way you did this morning
probably you know I don't think his
pants just appeared on him happy so he
he does the same thing you do every day
probably he's a human being and so calm
down he was about to throw up I know
that's vulgar but that's he was
everybody kept walking past them I said
you all right man you know he's read you
know and so he calmed down and later on
I what the lodge came back at he's in
the hall and it's a guy man thanks you
saved me you know I didn't mean to you
know almost save you enough like it but
I just want you to know that these are
people in that room you know they've got
something you need that you got
something they need they need you more
than you need them and that's why I keep
coming the Hollywood because think about
it I mean if they don't have stories how
Hollywood doesn't exist that's the way I
keep myself going anyway how many people
were in the room when you were pitching
I'd say about 15 companies at the time
and so each had someone at their at
their table oh yeah so maybe a little
more but and there's no one else from
the pitch fest in the room it's just
it's just I think they have the the
moderator if you will the person that
says time and uh yeah means the bell
rings the bell yeah yeah that's funny is
there anything that looking back on it
you said you know what I should have
done this I should have explained this
differently oh yeah actually you know I
always have I do a critique after you
know everything I do and I could have
said this what about this part you know
so no regrets but just to make it make
it stronger so I usually take notes and
then add that if it's you know sometimes
you just don't have time to do it but if
you can yeah so it sounds like good
advice that you would give to other
filmmakers and I'm just assuming this is
just to find something that you're just
so driven by yeah cuz it sounds like no
matter who tells you yes or no or it
needs to be more this or that right
you're still gonna keep going because
this is very this is what you it's it's
my passion yeah and you know I use the
word passion
uh yeah I'd have to say that uh yes I'm
passionate about it but but I guess more
so I'm interested in people seeing what
I've seen more than that I want them to
see and maybe there's a conversation
that can be had about why these kids are
this way how the health in my opinion
the families of you know pretty much
break it down those told you earlier
about the kid that had the doctors as
parents it was drawn up he had the plans
to the school but he told me and I
actually put this in my boat you know I
changed a few words but anyway I he told
me he said you know his parents were
arguing in my office they did want to be
there in the first place why is my kid
here he didn't do anything and you're
that kind of thing we've got more
important things to do to be here and so
they were fussing and so he looked over
at me and he said you see why I smoke
weed and you see why I want to do
something to put my name on the map they
never pay attention look at that so yeah
so those kind of things I want people to
see and have a conversation about so
that's that's kind of more than passion
I want people to actually see this stuff
and and maybe you know and I hate to say
this but every time a new politician
comes into if it's my state and they
lean a certain way they take away
funding for the social programs to help
these kids stay off the street and my
hate my state happens to be one of the
you know the biggest doing that my
funding was 50,000 a year it cost 32,000
to lock up a kid because it this
particular year they were asking for the
flag to come down on the Confederate
flag to come down one politician said to
me as I was at the General Assembly
begging for money me and all the other
arbitrators he said I tell you what
we'll give you a little 50,000 if you
leave that flag up there and so that's
what we dealt with we ended up getting
the money anyway but that's what we
dealt with yeah so I'm like I'm not the
kind of person it'll stick it in your
face
look what we did and I'm still going i'm
still standing but i want people to see
that and i put that piece in the
screenplay you know every time something
happens they want to touch the juvenile
crime money and so they lay off people
at the schools or whatever so yeah
that's what I want people see what do
you show in some of your scenes on how
to approach a kid that's at risk and so
you're not that authority figure down on
them which yeah rarely works that that
technique rarely works with kids you
know let me say that that uh because
kids are so desensitized these days you
can't scare him first of all the scared
straight thing it doesn't work kids look
at you and laugh they blow up stuff on
the video game all day you know and they
watch stuff on YouTube all day so you
know at the least a lot of the kids I
deal with that would be sensitized so if
you come in with this this attitude
where you're going to preach at them or
talk down at them and young man pull
your pants up that just doesn't work you
have to relate in some kind of way I'm
not saying to be fake about it kids can
tell you the real deal every time
because kids are used to dealing with
the real deal they'll tell you man be
real you know because they can spot a
fake and so what you have to do is you
have to be as real as the other people
on the streets are for instance I had a
kid who walked into my office and he
said mr. ray I ain't going to jail I
ain't worried about this I'll beat this
rap well if he had seen it on a movie
right and I said okay well i'll just
send you back to court because I'm the
only thing that stands between you and
this juvenile court he said to go ahead
no problem send me so I sent him two
weeks later I walk in the courtroom and
sit in the back to watch my case before
the judge at the time to pocket just
gotten arrested in Atlanta and when the
judge talked to him he turned around it
wouldn't
I was a judge the judge was talking to
his back the kid did the same thing he
turned around and he said talk to my
back so you can't fake it with these
kids you have to be real so that's what
I tried to do in my peace and my book
that's what try to do and also to
gaining having them gain your trust when
mostly adults they probably didn't trust
and that's why they're there yeah yeah
yeah yeah you have to gain a trust I've
been there you know I have to say I've
never done a drug I've never been in
trouble but I've been there I was the
guy that everybody would say hey Curtis
man don't tell anybody this but you know
I was always that guy you know I was
never the guy that actually did the
stuff but I was around the people who
did it I wasn't foolish enough because I
had seven uncles who say they kill me if
I did while they smoked weed by the way
I don't ever do this I'll kill you but I
listened you know to those guys my
uncles and I would say you know maybe
they're right I shouldn't do that and so
I could relate because I grew up with
those guys most of my friends are the UH
have been in jail I've lost seven
friends and I didn't grow up in what we
call the hood I grew up in middle-class
America so to say seven guys from
middle-class America died because of
crime it's pretty big deal but but I can
relate because I've grown up around this
and so when I talk to a kid you know I
don't sugarcoat anything if you do
you're already it holds you at arm's
length so I try to be as real as I can
with them and that's the way I come
across in my writing as part of a
problem for some people because it's too
rough for them you know it's definitely
for cable HBO showtime something like
that